how you doing people welcome to the
Ruben report i'm still dave rubin I've
got Aaron Foley and Maz Jobrani with me
and let's get right to it have you heard
about the camel people are freaking out
about the camel in Pakistan let's take a
look at the camel and then we'll talk
about the camel this is a that's not a
real camel don't worry about that that's
not some sort of Star Wars camel this is
a sculpture of a camel that is going to
cost the US State Department four
hundred thousand dollars to put at our
American Embassy being built in
islamabad pakistan and it is causing an
uproar so let's well let's first go to
the State Department's official document
explaining why this camel is worth four
hundred thousand dollars this artist
product is uniquely qualified public art
which will be presented in the new
embassy should reflect the values of a
predominantly Islamist country that's
according to the State Department ok
that sounds fine to me and just as a
little side note also in the Bible and
in the Quran they both use the metaphor
of a camel passing through the eye of a
needle so there's some religious
background there they're not just
randomly picking something but you know
what the 400,000 seems like a lot
apparently we have some economic
problems here and representative jason
Chaffetz he's not happy about this the
American people have a right to know
that their tax dollars are being spent
responsibly especially for art that the
vast majority of US citizens will never
have the opportunity to view and
basically there's been a whole big
Twitter firestorm as there is about
everything four hundred thousand dollars
for a camel Maz your persian so you know
bit about this type yes area of the
world so take it away well first of all
it's kind of racist i think to have a
camel art piece in pakistan that's like
oh they'll like but you know what are
you gonna go to Africa and put a
watermelon there
what are we doing here people State
Department that's number one and
secondly yes a lot of money I should I
should have gotten into art yeah does a
camel why was I what it is you know III
post a lot of art events and I don't
know if you guys is comics got you know
would hold any artists and and the money
that they spend on some of these things
and I'm just in there obviously because
you sit there you go I could have done
that that is it's just paint on a canvas
yeah but somehow this person became hot
and that's how much is worse at worth
and I'm sure maybe we'll watch me do
stand-up a lot of times ago I can do
that pay for this yeah yeah well the key
the key of course is to cut your ear off
and then your art value yeah goes way up
Aaron I know you're a you don't like to
spend the money am i right you like your
strict conservative when it comes to
Americans for money nyquil I could be on
I that up what do you think four hundred
thousand dollars is too much for this
type of thing well you know it's a camel
i I just thought like you know Americans
we pride ourselves on knockoffs like I
feel like you can give me like 10 grand
like a build you a camel its particulars
400,000 out like if you take the whole
needle out of it it's just like a stupid
ceramic camel it's pretending this is a
real camel I mean that's that haha
that's funny we should have just had a
hey with real camel you just get a gig
you just have a few camels when you
arrive at the Embassy in Pakistan and
then that's when you really would go oh
I'm in Pakistan yeah yeah that's like
Egypt isn't worth the other thing is a
good account is it a Trojan camel are we
gonna hide like CIA CIA spies inside the
cable that late at night we're gonna
solve through it and be like we're gonna
get the bad guys Papa I think that's
what it is that maybe that's why they're
paying the money cuz their BF cuz
anything about hey mr. general musharraf
oh yeah pakistan see ya why didn't I you
that behavior he's on trial but they go
hey general so-and-so hey why don't you
take this camera home for a week and
he's like oh of course I would do it
it never get this secret that's what it
is yeah I might be a Trojan cam I do you
think I could think of that was four
hundred thousand dollars and then my of
course my second thought was I obviously
immediately have to be a sculptor yeah
our morning yeah clearly yeah uh I knew
we could bring this to the NSA somehow
uh is this one of these things though
where the government is always spending
a [ __ ] load of money on everything every
embassy everywhere so I don't even think
this has anything to do with Pakistan
and the camel like they're doing this
all the time so should we ever get upset
about this or is this exactly what we
should get upset about cuz we're just
pissing money away everywhere as long as
we don't have to mention Benghazi uh
then I think we're fine maybe they're
trying to be like oh well who is gonna
run how do we get out of the Benghazi
let's do four thousand dollars in the
camp on another ever the others listen
if that they have some sort of budget
set aside ya are I did not miss comic
books yeah no taxes yeah but that well
and also it said uh the four thousand
dollar price tag is actually a very
reduced price for the sculpture I'm like
it's a cam yeah which I really find that
hard to believe that anyone gave the US
government a reduced price and he has
the US government ever bought anything
at a reduced price you know they do that
mean I've what this guy is saying is
with that what that's what that's what
blows your mind you like wait some some
a-hole paid even more for the camel
right but they're like yeah we got a
better facility came up with the whole
needle metaphor obviously you know
anything like they're like all right
well the camels alone just a camel but
we stick a needle and then you know
bring it from the Bible and the current
like I just can't like that's culturally
fatal what the needle means I have it
written right here so it's the it's the
camel contemplating needle which is it
so the camels made of fiberglass and
it's a play on the New Testament phrase
about the difficulty that the wealthy
have entering heaven of course the
wealthy are the only ones that can
afford a four hundred thousand dollar
camel so I go that's Lord the artist
wasn't thinking about this when he like
busted out a camel you know I mean it's
like we then we were like our let's get
the needle and make this work like he
was just like I'm gonna make a cam all
there's also funny we just said is it is
true it's like that it is is as metaphor
of like you know the poor shall inherit
the
but only the rich can acces by the camel
actually like in that interesting yeah
be better for that we can afford that
you guys can never be able to for this
camel uh is this a really good argument
though seriously for for lowering taxes
because we just put endless tax money
into everything and they just piss it
away so is this could this be something
I can see the Republicans first off cuz
it's Pakistan that scares people but
then also been saying well see where
they're pissing your money away and I
think this is the type of thing that
people might be like yeah we shouldn't
be doing this but the question becomes
again what is it like if they've got a
real budget set aside for if it were
like a thing where that you know you
guys know like colleges were sometimes
say we have to hire performers because
we have this money set aside and we'll
use it we lose it yeah so maybe that's
if it's that situation with the guys
like I have to spend four hundred
thousand what can we find like we got a
camel he's like I let's get the camel he
doesn't care they are care if this that
situation that then then we gotta go and
go why are we putting such a big budget
on art at the Embassy in Pakistan other
you do want to make the embassy look
nice can't just be pictures of
presidents and stuff but you know I
don't know all right so we talk a lot
about the one percent on the show and an
interesting study came out by Sadoff
Investment Research breaking down some
of the economics of what's going on in
America today so this is from 2012 the
average household income of Americans is
about thirty thousand dollars the
average household of the top one
percenters is about 1.2 million which is
41 times the average family's income the
average household of the top point one
percent is about six million which is
206 times the average family's income so
what I think is interesting about this
is that you know when you think of the
one percent I think people think this is
these are the people that have like you
know an armada of planes and houses
everywhere etcetera etc now they do have
over a million bucks which I think
probably all we all aspire to have and
this is America everybody should have
something but should we be focusing more
on that point one percent than the one
percent because that point one that six
million that's sort of where you're
getting into the ultra-rich although
even that is still leaving out all the
Zuckerberg xand the people that really
have
the big power I've given you a lot to
chew on there well I don't know where to
begin I never think about the point % 1%
I don't I mean like it just it's so like
after that number gets so largest like
it's absolutely meaningless to me it's
like an make six million a year I'm like
great could be six billion i don't know
like it's so ridiculous my first thought
was like well you know it said like on
Obama's watch I'm like well I guess the
only good information is if it was on a
Republicans watch we'd be talking about
the point 0 0 1 making 12 million a year
or something like that you know there's
only so much you can do but at the end
of the day everyone's got these sweet
notions that like oh our country was
founded on democracy it's capitalism I
mean capitalism Trump's democracy and
you can't really blame people for going
in you know into these money markets
into these hedge fund jobs they want to
make a lot of money that's their thing
and they make a lot of money and it's
like it's it's a really hard point you
just hope that they at the end of you
hope that they give back right that
you're making all this money that maybe
you can take you you know your personal
wealth and do good things with it and if
you don't you just hope you know that
they're miserable you know that they're
horrible miserable people are they ever
miserable that's the question they're
never deserve a six million dollars
first of all no I look it it's the it's
the it's the things that you I remember
when Warren Buffett was saying at one
point thing when the economy's crashing
that based on the taxes he was paying
because a lot of his income was off of
investments he's paying like I'm like a
fifteen percent right whereas like like
normal people pain like thirty forty
percent so he was making a point about
that first of all about you know the
thing of taxing the rich a little bit
more in finding ways to get money from
them and the other thing is i just heard
yesterday it was saying some company for
the company was one of these big
companies caterpillar was a caterpillar
was uh underpaid like two billion
dollars in taxes or something because
they found ways to do it they moved all
their profits to to a swiss bank account
yeah so that's where you go as we get
upset you go dude like I you know I'm
paying out every dollar I make I'm
paying fifty cents of that to the
government and there's these big
companies are finding loopholes so
that's where you go come on man you know
let's let's spread a little bit that
well I always thought that the warrant
everything was kind interesting cuz he
would always say well my secretary is
paying higher tax than I am which always
made me think well why you paying her so
little they like if you'd pay her more
than she closer to your tax bracket
should be doing okay Pater with stocks
then then she would pay then then she
would not pay this you pay less tax but
it's because income yeah so that's
that's where you get screwed yeah so the
part that you brought up is what this
article that was analyzing this was also
saying is that this gap between the
ultra rich and the poor has gotten
significantly bigger under Obama and I
think we think we all think somehow that
it's the Republicans that are really bad
about this but this is one of these
things where Obama has dropped the ball
cuz the facts are the facts I don't know
if he's dropped the ball I just don't
know how much he can do you know in a
way it's like you do you talk about Wall
Street Reform Oh Wall Street that money
feels lobbyists and it fuels Congress
like there's only so much you're gonna
do to stop this money you know I mean I
just feel like it's you know it's it's
like that thing when they were like oh
praise you run for president you know
you're like the most popular woman on
the planet and she's like well why would
I give up all that power you know what I
mean so it's so I don't know my energy
can blot blame Obama constantly I mean
on Obama's election night all the bigwig
Republicans like got in that room and
they're like we're gonna do one thing
we're gonna block everything that he
intends to do and they have or they've
been very successful at that so I don't
know if you can keep going back with
Obamacare I don't think they like black
people yeah well that's that no it's
listen it's naive to think that one
person is gonna make you know be able to
run everything and all you got to do is
watch house of cards and you realize the
vice president could be pulling the
strings yeah you know and there's a lot
of things that are you know backdoor
deals being made and it's just it's a
systemic thing unfortunately you know a
lot of other countries do tax you pay
more taxes but you you know you don't
have homeless people for example so is
the choice that we have to make do we
want to pay less taxes and have almost
people or more taxes and not have almost
people was that how sakaki reference
your way of telling us that you think
Biden is killed someone I think why this
definitely kill someone and
duh it's a great show yeah it is a
pretty great job um how should we
generally feel about the super rich
people i'm not even talking about that
one percent then the the six million
people you know the people that are
bringing in six min dollar i'm talking
about the the real the billionaire
billionaire people should we be like
this george soros this week just met
with all the potential Republican 2016
guys maybe it's like they have to go
kiss the ring just some rich guy yeah
it's pretty it's pretty sick right well
I mean this morning it comes down and we
have now less you know restrictions on
who can pay who to run for election it's
just yeah preme course yeah Thank You
Supreme Court wait a real it end Supreme
Court uh so now I can give my you know
ten bucks to the Democrats I don't know
it's it's it's so you know it is when
you really think about it if you feel
powerless and its really horribly
discouraging but then you're like oh
there's a sale on wine and that solves a
lot of my problems when I think about
the super rich yeah so how do you feel
it's like listen man if they made the
money they want to do what they want to
do they can do it it's just uh it the
the the one thing that you do start
worrying about is if the the disparity
continues then you know if you look at
history every revolution has many
revolutions been is based on a con
economics yeah so eventually there's
gonna be a breaking point and so I think
at some point the the country doesn't
need to step back and go okay let's we
can't have that many more people that
are that are poor and this few that are
rich because eventually something will
ya 206 times the amount of the average
income these people are making seems
like a bit much yeah and the loopholes
it is it's infuriating and now you know
it's unfortunate but now everyone's
armed so I mean it literally it could
happen it could happen well on that
positive note happy Wednesday as Aaron
mentioned the Supreme Court made a
horrific decision this morning which is
even going to put more money into the
political system we'll talk about that
next week but let's move on did you know
that Darth Vader the evil Sith Lord is
running for president of the Ukraine but
don't take my word for it we've got
video proof
in all my Lafayette nervous didn't
appreciate when William forget nothing
golly gee la Rosa new to him he talked
about his evening okay well he's got my
vote all right so this is actually only
partially a joke uh so Darth Vader this
guy did run in 2012 he was not on the
ballot but he got three percent of the
writings which is completely insane they
threw that out because they don't even
count the writings but he did get three
percent that's a pretty decent
percentage for a Sith Lord uh what are
some of his political actions let's find
out in 2013 he was carried in a sedan
chair by a group of Imperial
Stormtroopers to Odessa see all
declaring himself acting mayor of the
city citing an order by Emperor
Palpatine and as I said he scored a
record three percent of the vote in 2012
parliamentary election and the votes
were never registered because they were
writings which rendered them void under
Ukrainian law but he actually this
actually is becoming something he's
running uh on the Ukrainian internet
party and uh oh and you love this so to
run you have to get you have to raise
two hundred and thirty six thousand
dollars the party has already done that
for him so yes this is obviously a joke
and we can be joking about it but he's
actually doing this too so is this sort
of what we needed to i get a little
sense out of ukraine thing cuz
everybody's talking about here nobody
sure what's going on can Star Wars give
us a little momentary oh yeah this is
the greatest thing that's ever happened
to politics I mean I want to like you
know raise some money and then you know
your big golden girls family well you
know try to run for election as her
favorite golden girl I mean there's so
many aim for Betty White oh my god I
would tell a secretary I drip for all of
them uh yeah you know I think it's it's
uh it's absolutely it's so absurd I mean
Putin is so absurd the whole situation
so absurd so why not have Darth Vader
it's a basic how James Earl Jones can
throw his voice like that really really
I mean the guy's voice was was pretty
good speaks Ukrainian or Russian what
would that be
like well what is it was a Ukrainian I
think it was my little via oh no I know
do you think Putin actually envies this
guy little keep Putin sorta would like
to rule like our theta right if Putin is
a badass he just crushes people well I
think that he probably saw this and is
like you would destroy Darth Vader for
you know like he's even more evil yeah
which actually made me thing like the
guy like the it would be interesting if
they get like a mark hamill look alike I
said Luke Skywalker is running then
there's like the good that could be kind
of fun people are drawn to the dark side
though right if you were gonna vote for
one or the other you'd probably vote
dark side with her all dogs I mean the
whole bush administration access to evil
kill it was all it was all use all the
Star Wars i honestly think that's how
did explain that the george bush that
like i'm serious i honestly think that
they were like this okay Saddam
Hussein's like Darth Vader and you are
I'm service his fill yeah it's like evil
I get it okay you know what I well in
revenge of the sith you know there was
the big line that Bush said about you're
either with us or against us and revenge
of the sith which came out after that
they said it I mean Anakin Skywalker
says it to obi-wan Kenobi and you're
either with me or you're or you're my
enemies Falls with you know you like are
you still play with your puppets captain
are ya know that sings yeah it's just no
is Darth Vader is this like a third
party or is the it's the Ukrainian
internet market but I mean they're
actually raising the way do we need a
little this in our political system it's
such a mess here do we need some like
joke like either a comedian to run or
something crazy like this to really
didn't we've had well we've had what's
his name in minute with that Al Franken
in Minnesota the are no you pass away
now Gary Coleman ran for something Danny
Rose which are my West the most
efficient alice is not his whole
platform yes we talk about taxes yes we
can willis that was his whole thing oh
really talking about the point one
percent do we need like something like
that to shake of our system it's so
broken right it's so interesting to be
because like the situation ukraine is so
tenuous and it's so it's really like we
haven't seen this type of like
aggression in
what a long time you know we've seen the
aggression between like you know and you
know nor I was just about saying north
and south dakota north and says a lot of
varied said there's a lot going on there
and those numbers Dakotans let their
people leave i like it you tap mods when
you said that like you're from North
Dakota no you know yeah but you know you
know a country like taking over just
flat-out like oh I'm gonna take this
right and they you better be careful
we're gonna put you know our guards on
your border and stuff so it's so serious
and it's so like oh my god what's gonna
happen day to day that it's a little bit
surprising to me that there is a darth
vader like oh and hey listen i gotta you
know and we also have Darth Vader so
these are that kind of inspiring though
if I could seem like a great day I think
it's great i think darth vader should be
in every election yeah and yeah i really
do think the duc de darth vader should
run in every country he should write it
out my god yes regarth writer yeah um it
would be amazing you know how many
people honest to god you know how many
Americans would raise money and would
vote they would they would totally
they're so sick of both parties yeah
they're so if you if you had maybe like
not a darth vader but you if you had
like an american folk hero right like I
don't know like somewhat like a little
bit more positive in Darth Vader an
American folk Harris oh yeah like a Ted
Nugent listen no matter listen I ran for
eighth grade representative in junior
high school and I was the only one
running there was no so I had to wait I
had to wait I was gonna win yeah and I
got all the votes except one person to
write it and they wrote in Donald Duck
so I think if Donald Duck Rams I don't
that somebody like that somebody like I
gotta feel good I'm telling you they
would raise a lot of money and they
would get really far because people are
so sick of what's happening in like
Congress they're so sick of both parties
like if someone uh oh yeah Donald got
grand yeah I believe the final thought
on this what do you think George Lucas
thinks when he sees this stuff like he
just had this idea around 1974 this
little space idea and it became this
thing that is so beyond bonkers huge
culturally now politically he watches
his stuff and he's like this is some
crazy [ __ ] I was great I mean of course
can you think I mean like you know if if
you ever have you know you do TV show or
you do is
end up thing or you're on the show so he
runs up to and goes ash saw you in you
know thank you very much you know I mean
can you imagine this the level that this
guy his characters run a running for the
I mean that's crazy yeah right he
created a character they wanted to rule
the universe and now he has a guy
actually running yeah well how about
Superman Superman could run for
president in I today's I mean people
love Superman man I think I think anyone
I mean that's what if you did it like
American Idol style yeah you can end up
with the wrong people yep saying like is
if you get the right people voting the
wrong people anyway yeah yeah I mean a
Christina Aguilera could be running the
country because someone could be like
yeah boton well we need a lady there you
go I don't know about her but christina
aguilera 2016 there you go oh good god
all right let's talk about e-cigarettes
because you've probably been seeing
these commercials pop up all over the
place for e-cigarettes as if they're
somehow healthier than regular
cigarettes there seems to be some debate
about that but what's any cigarettes is
liquid nicotine it's the juice that's
used to refill e-cigarettes and it
apparently has some fatal effects if
it's ingested or absorbed by the skin
especially for children let's look at
the liquid look at that so that that
doesn't look like something that you
want to be putting in your body it looks
very chemically and gross and then you
smoke it and they get you get no smoke
so okay so according to the New York
Times if the liquid is ingested or
absorbed can lead to seizures and
potentially death that's not good even a
teaspoon of highly diluted eliquid can
kill a small child all right let's look
at a commercial for e-cigs in case you
haven't seen what I think you're gonna
recognize the lady let's doing this you
know I love being single but here's what
I don't love a kiss that taste like an
ashtray yeah I'm Jenny McCarthy and I
finally found a smarter alternative to
cigarettes Blu ecigs blue
vice me I get to have a blue without the
guilt because there's only vapor not
tobacco smoke that means no ash no odour
which also means i don't get the stink
eye from others also it doesn't make my
hair smell my teats turn yellow you get
the idea that's why I am in love with
blu ecigs now that I've switched to blue
I feel better about myself and I feel
free to have one almost anywhere but I'm
driving at home watching TV we're in I'm
in the club and no going outside in the
rain or freezing my butt off just to
take a puff I can whip out my blue not
worried about scaring that special
someone away no nothing finally with
blue I took back my freedom
okay that commercial is just horrible
but that aside let's just talk about
Jenny McCarthy for just a second before
we get into the to the real meat of this
thing Jenny McCarthy everyone knows
she's a huge proponent of the
anti-vaccine thing it's gotten her a lot
of trouble is it a little odd that
someone would take such a strong stance
on one thing that's medically
controversial and then she would lend
her name to this could be great Jenny
McCarthy be selling out for the
e-cigarette money mods what do you think
arm it is is very confusing the whole
thing because first of all um yet was I
guess is not there's none of research on
this and we're just kind of going with
it is that we're doing which pretty much
means it's going to kill you yeah and so
yes so if you're coming from that place
of like oh there's because the vaccine
thing is research saying it's good
reason is bad and so there's a lot but
this thing has no research right so yeah
well then the little bit it has a show
any they're not good yeah it's going go
with it yeah but doesn't this one what
is she thinking like really is this just
purely 1i like how does she think you
know we all talk about sellouts and like
how does she possibly think she can make
such a strong stand on one thing and
then let's jump on this thing I think
you're giving her too much credit like
she's thinking ahead and making plans um
I'm doing okay the money that I she came
back she took back her freedom uh that
was the slide I know I dishes been
personally incarcerated in her own hell
all these years but the e-cigarettes
overall you know finally a victory for
traditional smokers unbelievable that
like that's your thing now it's like oh
do the e-cigarette and you're like will
do Amin it died of cancer or kill a
small child there's so many so bad like
I thought we were in advance cuz there's
some countries we can get away with this
stuff where you go just go just do this
and we'll figure it out later yeah I
thought we were a little more advanced
but I guess we're not we're just like
throwing stuff out and going okay we'll
learn as we go well that's who is this
week while right hasn't the e-cigarettes
been out for it's been for a while but
now it's the marketing because now it's
the commercials that are popping up so
is this really just because of our love
of technology like they figured out a
way they were like oh cigarettes are
killing everybody we got bad PR can we
make this about technology everybody
loves technology
now it's blue and it's electric well
also but I mean that the way they sold
it to you was all I mean all the stuff
she listens good oh there's no smell and
they're all these are the sounds good to
me i don't smoke up great if you want to
do your thing fantastic fantastic and i
thought when it when i first saw it I
thought it's more like kind of like a
like a hook a bar where you go and you
know I thought it was whatever so I was
like oh these people just smoked in a
little bit of whatever I didn't really
yeah liquid we've seen that like if you
are you're out a night you trip over
let's see you're hammered you trip over
and you your e cigarette breaks like all
these babies around who died yeah all
the support your entourage your babies
they're always roll with a big entourage
and babies um do you guys think it's a
little weird that uh they're allowing
commercials for this cuz yes the science
isn't totally uh settled yet but they're
obviously some bad stuff going on here
we don't allow commercials for
cigarettes we haven't in a long time but
somehow they got around that because now
they're electric that's a good point is
this now these commercials running on TV
are they so they are i've seen these
commercials these is this company owned
by camel or one of the philip morris
there's got to be some one of these
cigarette companies has got to be
involved with this that is a good
question i don't know the answer or
exons got it something bad has this big
dark lord yeah also like it seems like
it needs like one of those seront life
spoof squirrels at the end it's like
this e-cigarette could cause the small
children to death like you know don't
don't you know open it don't put it near
like you know to mean Arthur what are
the warnings yeah I haven't heard of any
of these warnings I mean diarrhea they
attempted suicide all that kind of stuff
um what about the people that are gonna
say you have to let these e-cigarettes
exist and we have to be able to add
realism because of freedom what about
those people hey right listen man there
should be some rules on what you got you
gotta test this stuff at least on mice
and somebody test it on something before
you put you can't just put it out that's
like half these pills what you just said
smoking mouse that's just ridiculous hey
to see a snow gig like a little mouse
Mangler for cigarette geez you do you
find this year in comedy clubs all the
fine dit so annoying when people are
smoking an e-cigarette I literally say
to them I go you have one more puff and
that's a no I
is the most enough for me it's most I
look out you're having to deal with cell
phones and people being like down like
you know you have to deal with like
absolute chaos I wonder how stand up
works at all quite frankly and then
someone smoking e-cigarette and I said
to the lady I was like uh all right you
know please put that away super
distracting she goes oh no it's an
e-cigarette I go I don't care what it is
like just you're gonna need to stop
immediately yeah like it's so noisy
smoke it's really yeah since e cigarette
all right so you guys aren't gonna be
joining the e-cigarette but do you think
anyone that doesn't smoke is gonna join
this that's what I think is interesting
here like are they only marketing to the
people that smoke cigarettes or are they
actually trying to hook a new generation
oh I think they're terrific a new
generation tours yeah Jenny McCarthy
with her boobs hanging out in her face
that's been realigned I think that I
mean I think people are gonna be like oh
she's a hot blonde I don't want to smell
like smoke you know I'm gonna do yeah
for sure yeah if she would say in that
commercial look it tightened up my face
yeah then I'll be like all right I got
to start this huh all right from from
cigarettes to air let's talk about the
air in China which you guys probably
have seen a lot about we've done a
couple stories on it residents of zheng
jie zhao which is the pollution racked
capital of china's and nan province well
last Saturday they got a treat they were
provided with bright blue bags of fresh
air yeah this sounds made up or from a
comedy movie but not the case let's take
a look so yeah they got to go up into a
nearby mountain where the air originated
it's about 120 miles away from the city
that they live in and they got to suck
down some air for a while pretty good
and what you can see on the right there
this is actual canned air that is a can
of air that they're selling they're
actually selling that in China and what
did that remind me of well as president
of Planet spaceball I can assure both
you and your viewers that there's
absolutely no air shortage whatsoever
yes of course I've heard the same room
with myself yes thanks for calling and
not reversing the charges yeah fine
present oh yeah that's Mel Brooks
predicting the future in space balls I
can't believe you may have spaceballs
reference even before two and one Kevin
doing the show for a movie Polly
multi-engine dicing yeah the right guy
the UM all right so we'll do a little
jokey then this is actually pretty
serious is this crazy like is this
actually nuts that there are parts of
this planet right now where they are
living in so much smog you know we've
seen pictures where it looks like fog
but it's actually smog it is pure
pollution that they have to go to
mountain 120 miles way to get air yeah I
guess I wasn't giving you the funny part
first no the best line it says the
China's Providence received a treat on
thur everything a tree yeah like mine uh
it really has changed my perspective on
treats you know I'm always like Isles
let's get a dude's good to deltaco it'll
be a tree and they're like we just get
some air yeah you like an electric
cigarette but you know did you know its
air so frightening it's so frightening
they were like hey we've got a special
thing for our citizens air air what's
they get your felt like I have kids you
tell kids like you gotta eat it there's
people starving in Africa guys like you
better breathe this air there's people
with no air in China yeah yeah it's
frightening Ali frightening but the can
was kind of cool it was in the cab would
look so pleasant and yeah it would look
like like but doesn't a can seem like a
bad way to get air the other one where
you're sucking on the day it makes it
causing more pollution with aluminum
it's like an error so okay I'm just
waiting here they should do an
e-cigarette air air cigarette yes when
you get nicotine and air so it's good
and bad that's what we have to find the
Asian Jenny McCarthy yes Oh said if you
don't know we're talking about right now
we're gonna hesitate to the story before
this but cigarettes and air it's all
coming in one yeah in one big thing um
is this what can we do because you know
obviously this has something to do with
the amount of pollution that's going up
in
that I'm sorry your products from China
is that is that really certainly should
be over do we all with iphones you have
an iphone yes but my iphone okay so we
all have is my newest maybe tomorrow you
just have not in a box you don't even
touch i just you know i like i like i
want to keep the Chinese a boy okay but
nah but what really what do we do this
because they're going through their
industrial revolution now much like
India we've done it already so do we
have any right to tell them what to do
because look I mean this air eventually
is gonna get over here we know that the
water from Fukushima is coming to our
yeah the west coast of the United States
right now like we're all connected so
what do we do stop farting mmm no more
for one of the cow parts that is not
good yeah cow farts are bad so they
could tell us that ever know the cows
yeah i'm gonna start showering with
bottled water ah well yeah it's just
it's really disturbing that that china's
go to is not to like all right let's
crack down on the pollution let's let's
really you know figure out how we can do
air quality let's rein it in it's like
that ship these people on a bus to like
a higher area gears a little treat then
get back down there it looks like you
know what it looks it looks like when
the emergency landing system on an
airplane before they make up again let's
throw the image up against a second I
mean the [ __ ] plane drop an altitude
yeah that is what it does look like that
but yeah can you imagine I mean you know
look it's easy we could joke about it
but I mean these poor people had to
actually leave their homes and travel
120 miles into a mountain for air I mean
this is happening on planet earth is
this just like proof of every science
fiction movie ever I mean every week we
do a story that I feel like science
fiction is actually coming crew right
now like I'm like we are destroying our
earth yeah and you know we're gonna have
to move to Mars pretty soon yeah I mean
I never I was never one for investing in
any type of space travel honestly I feel
like I'm the only one that gets
adamantly opposed to like anything now
so does except for lower dead space turn
well you don't like pain I just was like
it feels to me what Sarah's most come on
that's crazy to me that we spend like 1
billion dollars on like arts on the moon
and no one has text books like I it
makes me insane but then you hear these
stories and you're like oh well we got
to get out of this planet at some point
so yeah do we have to leave the planet
at some point yes I yes we do we do we
give you get
a can of air and you just did actually
you go and it just takes you so I
thought this was really interesting
scientists are using mood drugs to help
adults learn new skills and improve
cognitive function let's look at some
info a Harvard professor used danza
pezzo a drug that's typically used to
treat Alzheimer's to rewire the brain of
a visually impaired woman after using
the drug the woman was able to process
images the way a newborn wood and
eventually regain normal sight he also
used an epilepsy drug called valproate
to teach tone deaf adults how to find
musical notes so this is pretty amazing
stuff and these are just two examples of
this kind of thing and there they
actually think that there's all kinds of
pills that they can give you that I'll
legitimately make you smarter we did a
story on rewiring your brain last week
that the Internet is actually rewiring
our brains because we look at phones so
much are we going to have like as our
super humans on the way we always think
it's robots that are going to take over
but you know if enough medication is out
there to change the way we think and the
problem is always the side effects
because they always go oh great and then
the go but you know your time good i got
the moon walk everywhere you go like
really i got a moon water yeah I take
that pill I do love to brood walk yeah
but no it just feels super creepy like
take this pill you'll hear sounds take
this like it just but also there's that
whole thing it says the pill helps
adults learn as fast as babies do and
like I was like it was talking about
this whole cognitive processing of
babies how they process information and
I was like really I want it it just
seems like babies like I don't like
they're like they don't seem extremely
intelligent to me like they don't be
like but there I think it took you you
to walk yeah my five years for you to be
like the complete sentence I mean how
long is this bill gonna take for me to
like do the Rubik's cubes yeah i think
it's the rate that they're learning
considering they were in just some money
yeah i just feel like you know if you're
gonna take a bill to rewire brain i
would want it quicker than like zero to
three years yeah if you could take a
pill to be smarter so what was that
movie with De Niro and yeah
whatever whatever Bradley Cooper a
brother we did would you want to take a
pill of course what I would i read it
was comical again I have kids and it
said that you said like up to six or
seven they really retain a lot and I was
like well I better start getting some
classes for these key leg but they can
of the piano lessons or something you
what is I mean it would be amazing if I
if you could take a pill and just retain
everything is how many times have we
like for example names touring is a
comedian how many times I've seen
somebody I'll be a a weekend at a club
and keep running the manager and the
waitress in the man just don't know what
their names are I need name tags you
know ya know it is it just feels like
that really it's a thing with America
you know what's wrong take a pill you
know you want to remember somebody to
take a pill how about you read a book
Kabul you know anything like it it
always seems to me like super it so it
was the fast cut all right yeah but I
mean this study was really exciting
because it it would help people like
traumatic brain injuries so I'll give
you that but like some fat ass on a
couch like I can't remember anything i'm
going to start popping these pills right
so i am i will say it to the camera i am
extrapolating a bit yes it was being
used for medical purposes and we're just
taking it to the next step there isn't
necessarily science behind all of this
but would part of the problem be that
only rich people would be or at least
wealthy people would be able to afford
this stuff and then you're gonna have
not just a divided by economics but
literally a smart divide yes papa it's i
mean hopefully if this technology ever
came to fruition and everyone could
could partake in it but cuz that's how
everything works right something good
happens everyone gets it without but
it's like I mean that unfortunately
you're right it'sit's this pill culture
like you go oh just take a pill get
smarter and unfortunate thing is we
don't put money towards education we
don't we don't help the poor you know
giving them opportunity and raising them
and and so you think I'll take a pill
you get smarter we have a capacity for
being smarter but now how are they gonna
get smarter if you know if you're not
teaching them it's it's very complicated
the offices that does it take a pill
yeah things will be fine yeah yeah but
yeah people think that way yeah all
right people it is very complicated
people do think that way and I hope you
got a little smarter here without taking
a pill but if you were taking a pillar
smoking something whether it's an
electron
cigarette or whatever it is that's fine
with us too I want to thank Aaron Foley
Maz Jobrani there twitterers are right
down below and we will do this again
next week thanks for watching